[Music]
hey guys it's ezra from grand rapids i
was listening to the pod the other day
and i remember you guys saying that
getting rich quick is the best way to
get rich so i'm just wondering what's
the fastest way you've had your life
changed by money or what's the fastest
way you've seen someone else's life get
changed by money thanks
all right we were asked what's the this
is a one question friday we are asked
what's the fastest that either of us
shawn and sam have jumped in wealth and
how it felt and or
the same question but for some of the
people we know you want to go first
uh no you go i think you you might have
a good story here
i'll talk about a friend first so i was
with a
friend that sold his company for close
to a billion dollars
and i was with him i was with him when
um the money hit the bank we were at
their apartment and immediately like
he's like all right i think it i think
it happened we went to the atm
he previously had like uh 300 000 in his
bank which is uh not a little amount so
he wasn't like destitute at all
but he was 28 and we went to the atm and
there was 90 million dollars in the bank
account
and immediately afterwards
we went to mcdonald's and we got a
number one
each we each got a big mac
and we went back to his apartment and
watched tv and like we're like that's
pretty cool isn't it and uh
it was really cool like it was pretty
crazy the crazy part is not just the 90
million but if you do the math of 90
million conservatively if you look at
historical average 90 million at let's
just run up to 100 100 million at 30
becomes 240 which becomes 450
which becomes 860 which becomes 1.1 at
70. 1.1 billion so you can see this it's
not just that they have 90 million
dollars it's like well you're it's a
sure fire away more likely than not that
you're gonna be a billionaire at some
point while you're alive
that was crazy
so uh that that's one story do you have
one
i got a couple so um we've told this one
on the pod before people are sort of
familiar but i'll do a fast version of
it which is million dollar homepage so
alex ii who is a friend and i think
you're friends with him as well he um
i think he was 21 years old and he was
like just i want to be a millionaire i
want a million dollars
how do i like do this and he kind of
asked himself this question which was
like how do i make a million dollars in
like the next like month or two you know
which is
um
not the question most people ask nobody
will teach you or recommend that you ask
this question but he asked it and guess
what the brain is a a question answering
machine and so you ask that question the
brain if you believe that everything is
possible we'll start to come up with
ideas and one of the ideas he came up
with this is back in uh i don't know
when million-dollar maybe like uh 2007
or 2006.
yeah something like that so basically
2005. he creates a million-dollar
homepage and he's basically like uh you
know
just like i don't know he's 19 20 21
years old something like that he's like
okay i'm gonna make a website that's a
thousand pixels by a thousand pixels
each pixel is just like a little square
and he's like cool every pixel is a
dollar and he kind of made it like at
the top it says be a part of it of
internet history and the set website's
still up you can go to million dollar
homepage.com and you can kind of you can
see all the pixels and so basically he
was like
if i sell each of these squares for one
dollar
i will make a million dollars and sure
enough he did uh january 11th uh the
final tally was 1 million 37 thousand
and 100
by the end of it and so he literally
made a million dollars and i asked him i
was like you know
how did you get like you know he
basically he built something that was
like designed to go viral so it was
almost so stupid and so like uh either
some people shared it because they
thought it was fun funny and cool and
other people thought it was dumb dumb
and dumber and so like you know either
way it evoked a reaction out of
everybody and so you can go there right
now you could see all the pictures that
pixels that sold and basically companies
would buy it because they thought oh if
this is gonna get a bunch of traffic
um then cool i might get a bunch of
clicks if i put my billboard here a
bunch of people have tried to replicate
this since but he made a million dollars
in i think two months uh time period and
um and then he went on to do something
and then he blew it over the course
he blew all the money in the course of
the next year just kind of having party
bought it off bought a condo uh you know
like he did what a 21 year old would do
and he was like oh i for sure i'm just
gonna dude i did it so easy the first
time i'm just gonna keep making hits i
don't have to worry about saving this i
can just blow it
and then i think it was 10 years of like
not having another hit trying thing
after thing after thing after thing
until he built calm and then calm took
several years before calm became a thing
and now calm is a
i don't know two billion dollar company
or something like that um in the
meditation space so kind of an amazing
story on his part
i um what i did starting at age 20
or i forget which age i was like two
years before my exit
i use personal capital or and as well
which is like mint.com it's just like
but different and you can manually add
stuff
and i manually added enough money that
it said my net worth was 16 or 17
million dollars
and so i had that on there and i just
started like seeing that number because
of course money you can buy stuff but in
a lot of cases it's really just like
this like number on a spreadsheet where
like you know it's just like a digital
thing like you could put three zeros
behind it and like it kind of starts
feeling real for a minute and that's
what i did and so i put that my net
worth was like 17 million dollars like
uh two years or a year and a half before
my exit and then when i got paid i
remember thinking like
this feels cool but then like 20 minutes
later i was like it kind of
i was i'm kind of used to this now
already like i see that number already
and so i would say i'm still getting
used to uh you're you're a manifesto i
am you what do what i think what do we
say we're the manifest cowboys baby i
manifest stuff that's what i do i'm not
a business person i'm a manifesto
you know
that's pretty good on the spot yeah
that's what i do
no small boy stuff i love that yeah
i'm not a businessman i'm a i'm a guy
who dreams and tries to achieve it it
just so happens that it's in the form of
business but that's what i did and it
made a difference and i actually noticed
it here but here's my i wrote this down
so
i felt a big difference when i had
twenty thousand dollars the next big
difference that i felt my life was when
i hit a hundred thousand dollars this is
all liquid net worth the next big
difference was when i hit 500 000 and
then the next one was 10 million and i
think that maybe
maybe like the 40 or 50 range will be
the next one and then maybe like the 100
range will be the next one that's what i
think but i remember feeling like
between like
uh 500 000 and like 10 million i kind of
almost felt the same
right right right yeah
similarly first jump was 25k
we won it in prize money for our startup
like at a business plan competition and
it was like oh sweet we can work on this
for the whole year
and just
this will be here this is the money we
need to live on and we need to so three
of us lived on 25k
for a year and a half or something like
that it was amazing and uh that was a
huge jump because it was freedom for a
year and a half to not think about money
to just try to build something cool i'll
also share something that's similar so
forget getting super rich quick which i
think is a good exercise to do um like
what would i do if i really wanted to
like 5x 10x if i wanted to make a
million dollars in three months what
would i do and if i wanted to do that
how would i do it uh worthwhile exercise
the other one is like
baby goals so i heard kevin hart on some
podcast and they were like kevin man you
you're now like the biggest movie star
in the world like you know you're up
there bro you have
your huge comedy specials movies you got
it all
like did you think that you could do
this he's like he's like well i never
really thought about it to be honest
like i just he's like i didn't think
like this huge goal because that would
almost
like it just seemed too too uh different
from where i was it wasn't really even
yet useful if i thought about it i could
say it but like it didn't matter because
i was so far from it he's like so i just
did baby goals like just here's a little
baby girl let me get to this point and
another baby goal another baby goal and
i actually think that baby goals are a
lot more useful and a lot less talked
about than like
having the big hairy audacious you know
dream and goal
you need both they're both useful at
different times but i would say most
people would should would probably be
better off doubling down on a baby goal
let me give you an example
when i was 21
we were working on our business our
startup and we had a business plan and
we had a an llc and we had all the like
important sounding things that we
thought it takes business cards we had a
logo
we had business cards people logo we had
a website we had a blog we had investor
we had like everything we thought it
takes to to do this
and um
so nine months go by and we're like this
was the sushi restaurant chain nine
months go by and we're like we've been
doing our planning and then we've been
doing our like getting the chef on board
and then we're trying to find a location
and then we're trying to figure out how
much does it cost to build it out all
the things you kind of gotta do to
launch this thing and i remember one day
just sitting there with my buddy trevor
and we were just like
god like i feel like we're just like
acting business we're playing playing
startup yeah you're playing house it's
like you know oh come over let's play
house let's play doctor it's like we're
playing business because we got this
like and literally it was it's
embarrassing we had a binder of a
business plan that was like 300 pages
and we used to brag about how well
thought through our business was like
we've thought through every detail what
are mine
what the uniforms will be what yeah
binders full full of plans in this case
and we had like here's how here's how
we're gonna do employee promotions
because we think that the way that
companies work is like all this [__]
that didn't matter and like again 21
years old too dumb to know that that
wasn't what was important uh until we
got we took it to a meeting and we got
sort of laughed at where the guy was
like oh like this is your business plan
and we're like yeah
it's a and we thunk this binder onto the
desk and he's like i'm not reading this
and we were like oh yeah that's okay but
just we wanted to show you we've thought
it through he goes
that means you're thinking about the
wrong things and we're like oh so kind
of we're getting we get this feeling
like maybe we're doing this wrong this
is about nine months in maybe we're
doing this wrong so we're just sitting
there when they were like
all right why don't we just like
for the weekend let's just make a
business and like let's just try to make
a thousand dollars
like can we make a thousand dollars in a
weekend 48 hours as a challenge to
ourselves can we get to a thousand
dollars and i swear i learned more about
like actually building a business in
that 48 hour thousand dollar challenge
that i did the entire year of like
working on the business because we were
like okay
how would we do this what's a product
that we think people want uh we don't
you know we're instead of like being
married to our current idea it's like
well what's a simple product that like
people want and my buddy was like oh we
used to live in boulder and he was like
trevor was like you know you ever seen
like every time we walk around campus
all the sorority girls and like frat
guys they all have these wristbands on
like the livestrong band but they have
this like stack of wristbands and he's
like there's this new one that's like a
really thick one it's like triple the
size and it's like i don't know that
seems to be in he's like what if we made
those like that seems like that's pretty
simple like to to sell those and we're
like oh yeah you could just like
customize it you could put like you know
the hustle on it or you could put like
milk road on or you could put like your
brand name or your your frat name or
whatever on it
that'd be cool i think we could sell
like a bunch of those
and so we're like okay
uh what should we call it and like
everything that we had been super
thought through and thoughtful about we
just like did in five seconds like
what's a good name what's a good name
for these like fat like wristband things
oh let's call it the fat band
and then we create the fatband.com
bought it on godaddy for in five seconds
uh logo here let me just use impact the
like thick font okay impact that's the
that's the logo boom done
um product okay let's not try to have
the best product like is there just
something on ali we had heard of alibaba
and i was like is there something on
alibaba or aliexpress that we could just
get these like made i didn't even know
the word drop shipping but we figured
out that same concept ourselves we're
like oh dude you just buy these for you
know 17 cents and then if you include
shipping it's only this much if we sold
each one for a dollar fifty like that
would work we could do it we'd only need
to sell whatever it was like we only
need to sell 700 bands in order to make
a thousand dollars and hey that's
actually we could even be profitable if
we did it it's like all right well how
do we sell this thing
we only have you know like 24 hours left
and so we just started like posting on
our own facebook pages and calling like
anybody who we could think of to be like
hey would you do you want this for your
sorority do you want this for your your
group
and like we found one
girl who he used to date who like
basically she bought she was like oh my
parents are having an anniversary party
and there's like 200 people coming i'll
take like 250 of them and we like made a
sale and we're like yeah just like read
out your credit card i don't even know
how we took the payment like we didn't
even have anything to take payment we
just like took the payment somewhere
that paypaled us or something
and dude that feeling of getting to a
thousand dollars
like you could see the smile on my face
i still feel that how good that felt
that weekend and that was when i first
was like
oh this is what it feels like to do
something real everything else we've
been doing is fake and like i was so
obvious to me and it changed the way we
did our main business too
and like that thing paid for like you
know a little bit of side hustle money
as we went
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
so i've built maybe seven or eight
different businesses whether that just
be like a real estate thing or the
hustle or a court or just whatever
i think almost all of them i got to a
hundred thousand in sales before i filed
an llc
and the reason i do that is momentum and
like people are like ben's laughing and
people are like oh it's illegal first i
don't think that's illegal you can use
your social security number and like get
a lot of the stuff like you can like
enter your social security number and
second
i have no idea it actually might be
illegal but like i don't care because
i'm willing to like sacrifice those
things and get in trouble for the sake
of momentum because momentum is like the
lifeblood like when you're going because
once you start getting sales it gets
addicting and you like taste you taste
it and it works out amazing listen to
this so there's this um
so i tweeted out that i want to dress
better
and this guy who's got like a fashion
instagram thing uh what's it called like
well-built style or something like that
he d on me and he's like hey like look
at my instagram like i think it fits
what you want and i go yeah this
actually is great he goes tell you what
i'm gonna make you a presentation on all
the things that you buy just send me a
pinterest board of the people who you
admire and like your personality and
i'll study your instagram and study your
twitter to understand your body and your
personality things like that and i'm
going to send you a p uh a powerpoint
with like image like it looks for you
and then just a link to buy like all
these clothes i said all right great
what's in it for you he goes if you like
it pay me 300
and so he spent like a week doing this
and he sent it to me i was like this is
sick man i would have paid way more than
300 by the way and i just he goes he
goes well that's awesome here's my email
just paypal me 300 bucks and i did it
and this is a beautiful perfect example
of a person who just they just did it
they did it the right way and it just
worked and like then you do that maybe
10 more times and then eventually you
quit you create a questionnaire on your
website and then you like do a pay half
up front and then you do this and then
you do that and then you hire a couple
more people like it turns into [__]
really fast we don't plan like well how
many people would buy this you really
just think like
well how big do i want it to be and like
would
a million people buy this over the
course of three years yeah maybe that
sounds about right all right that's cool
let's do it
and
that's typically how it works for me and
uh i think that's how it should work for
most people in most cases not all the
time some guys are starting big
companies like car companies and [__]
like that and that doesn't require
planning but for most people most of the
time this works
the the question was about getting rich
quick and i think
my takeaways are
there is a benefit to actually thinking
through how would i do it if i wanted to
like let me not just be like
pretend to be morally opposed to the
idea of getting my outcome faster right
i think it's fine getting rescued gets a
bad rap but like i think we all would
love to get to our dream outcomes faster
if possible might as well ask the
question could i get there really fast
and what does the brain come up with
you're not obligated to do it second
thing is instead of focusing on getting
rich quick i would say get revenue quick
especially if you're kind of like early
in your entrepreneurial career because
getting any revenue quick will like make
the whole thing real you'll stop playing
startup and you'll actually be in the
game you'll feel what's real it'll force
you to focus on the only the stuff that
matters and you won't end up like me
with a 300 page binder full of business
plans like it's almost like a caricature
how dumb that was
but it's like i took it to the extreme
end of like the wrong way to build a
business is like to
super over plan and never like go to
market and actually try your thing um
and you know the fat band thing that i
did was by far the best thing i did
early on in my my kind of
entrepreneurial thing didn't get rich
off of it but in a way i did because i
actually learned about how to do a
business for real which is what ended up
helping me become wealthy but you know
that skill ended up helping me become
wealthy that experience did it was like
enough money to get like a bloomin onion
and maybe a steak dinner at outback
steakhouse so i consider that a success
right that's all you want now we were
big on that
fondue place has you ever been to a
fondue place i feel like you're like
lactose intolerant you're probably i
could i could see that you're lactose
intolerant yeah dude are you there you
see i look like the embodiment of a
glass of milk like it looks like i just
eat potatoes milk and corn all day
like when you're talking about that
fashion guy
he was like you know i i think you got
potential you you're a tall tall drink
of water and it's like a tall glass of
milk
i get it straight from the udder every
morning yeah i mean look at me
i'm like a melting bar of chocolate
like a melting piece of fudge you're a
tall drink of milk
yeah yeah if corn were a human it would
look like me
uh yeah
you ever thought
about if a corn on the cob had legs yeah
yeah
all right
that's the sign that we're done see ya
[Music]
you